what did the 2010s add up to
I spent the decade at reason creating
videos about the democratization of
everything and the declining power of
society's gatekeepers media theorist
Marshall McLuhan who coined the axiom
the medium is the message
argued that history's prime mover isn't
the great leader or great thinker but
ever-changing communications
technologies everything that we prize in
our Western world in matters of
individualism separatism a unique point
of view a private judgement all those
factors are highly favored by the
printed word and not really favored by
other forms as societies moved from oral
traditions to written ones McLuhan
argued there was a cultural shift tribal
groups who relied on face-to-face
communication and mythology morphed into
more complex less homogeneous societies
thanks to the written word and when the
printing press standardized
communications the distribution of
literature created the very concept of a
public bound together by common
languages and texts this set the stage
for the rise of modern nation-states in
the Enlightenment millions of words
across our little miles in the 1960s
McLuhan identified our current epoch as
the electric age in which circuit based
media gave rise to what he termed the
global village for the first time in
history the entire world could follow a
single event
McLuhan predicted that this electric
global village would undo both the
National homogeneity and personal
individuality engendered by print
reviving our more fractured and tribal
past where reach rival Isaac
involuntarily we're getting rid of
individualism we're more concerned with
what the group knows the feeling as it
does of acting with it and as the
electric age has evolved into the
digital age with its cheap limitless
replicability this retry belies a ssin
has accelerated in the 2010s
which is why the past decade has both
created opportunities and dangers for
the libertarian and liberal worldviews
what we have already achieved gives us
hope the audacity to hope for what we
can and must achieve tomorrow Barack
Obama epitomize
the best and worst of the decade as a
longshot candidate he used new modes of
communication to route around and
eventually co-opt media gatekeepers
he built a cult of personality through
social media using inspiring rhetoric so
vague that people could project anything
onto his words
forgotten what this country has already
done what free men and women can achieve
when imagination is joined to common
purpose
the Obama White House produced and
distributed its own content undermining
the establishments ability to define him
photojournalists for example were denied
access to the president's most intimate
moments but were free to publish the
selective imagery of the official White
House photographer the White House went
to create an identity for the President
and because they can distribute directly
through all these different channels
there's really not much downside to it
there's not much accountability Obama
wasn't the only one who understood new
media better than the gatekeepers
disruptive figures like Andrew Breitbart
I'm here coincidentally I just arrived
and James O'Keefe embarrassed the
establishment bringing down national
political organizations like acorn and
Congressman Anthony Weiner and casting
doubt on media narratives about the
emerging Tea Party movement the same
dynamic was at play when teenage boys
were accused of harassing a Native
American elder at the Lincoln Memorial
until reasons own Ravi suave did a more
thorough analysis of the raw cell phone
footage when you're reporting something
that confirms all of your biases you
have to be really sure you have to
consider evidence that conflicts with
that Occupy Wall Street protestors
capitalized on the digital age to gain
widespread attention for their movement
and of course there's Edward Snowden who
carefully selected his own gatekeepers
to bring US government secrets out into
the open and then spoke directly to the
public to defend his actions over time
that awareness of wrongdoing sort of
builds up and you feel compelled to talk
about it DIY culture is hardly new but
the 2010 czar when journalists
governments and the public at large were
forced to take it seriously
renegade gunsmith Cody Wilson created
not just the 3d printed gun but just as
importantly content about the 3d printed
gun if you only knew that
like embarrassing vulnerable like
physicality of these things these
objects would just crumple and fall
apart so the media cannot help
themselves if I can get something 80% of
the way they will take it to its
completion and then a bit further than
that Wilson also epitomized the
permissionless attitude that accelerated
in the 2010s by enabling his customers
to make firearms without the involvement
of the state we're trying to push
through facts on the ground that changed
what the political reality is
independent of our institutions
hopefully one day won't matter what
these men and women black robes say
because you just know that you can
download the air 15 from the internet
crank one out in your garage crank two
out in your garage or take DIY genetic
engineering kits pioneered by former
NASA biologists turned biohacking
entrepreneur Josiah Zener our people
dying and suffering needlessly because
all these committees and all these rules
and what happens if people just start
saying like [ __ ] you I'm gonna do it
anyway
and what if people start getting cured
Ross Ulbricht launched the first but not
last dark web drug market is about
punishment and making him an example and
uber lyft an Airbnb disrupted and
undermined entrenched industries with
ubiquitous pocket computers you cannot
cope with vast amounts of information in
the old fragmentary classified patterns
you tend to go looking for mythic and
structural forms in order to manage such
complex data and moving at very high
speeds if Obama mastered the use of new
media to control image and messaging
Trump exploited its tendency to
discombobulate and retry belies he
probably will win the presidency based
just on skill cartoonist and writer
Scott Adams predicted a trump victory
more than a year before the election
after observing his persuasion tactics
it's more of a strategy than you
imagined it is I've said that if Trump
wins it might change how we see the
world not just how we see politics but
how we see humans and how humans are
influenced and how little reason has
anything to do with what we do political
scientists will debate the various
reasons for Trump's victory for years
but with his background in reality TV
and mass marketing
there's little doubt he excels at making
himself heard by an American public
stretched thin by an increasingly
overwhelming flow of information
Trump's concepts and phrases stick in
our minds tonight I like you our fake
news something going on and it's bad in
Chicago it's a wind chime about the
Winchester foreign actors capitalized on
the declining trust and institutions to
spread their own propaganda so it's not
surprising that many people yearn for
the return of the gatekeepers oh this
hate and violence is being facilitated
by a handful of Internet companies that
amount to the greatest propaganda
machine in history Congress demanded
that Facebook Twitter and Google do
something the gatekeepers tried to
reassert power Twitter and Google
punished users for violating their vague
and overly broad Terms of Service which
were partly exported to the US from more
sensorial jurisdictions things that
would be politically difficult and
perhaps unconstitutional or in some
cases certainly unconstitutional to
mandate here we don't have to even
consider because they get mandated in
Europe and then companies apply them
globally the medium is not something
neutral it does something to people it
takes hold of them it roughs them up it
massages them and bump them around but
if McLuhan is right there's no reverting
to the old days his technological
determinism will seem bleak to some but
his analysis also offers a path to
personal agency and self-awareness if
you take some violent and irritating
process say like radio or TV and start
looking at how it works what it's doing
to you and why it's doing it to you you
can get very enthralled very excited
what kind of media do you want not what
kind of press or set of journalists but
through what technological means do you
want to communicate and get information
if the 2010s were the decade of the
stream or the feed what if the 2020s
bring the return of the channel content
giants like Netflix and Disney are in a
mad scramble to lock their copyright
behind subscription paywalls roughly
reconstituting the branded TV channels
that cord cutters thought they left
behind
but they're also part of a consequential
shift towards driving revenue from
subscriptions instead of advertising
which generates a more direct
relationship between content consumer
and producer and we've already begun to
see dedicated encrypted communication
channels supplant public time lines and
further fracture mass media following
the habits of its users even Facebook
has pivoted hard away from the newsfeed
towards private groups in chat could the
revived channel with its emphasis on
personalization and constant exchange
signal a return of community privacy and
free thought in the 2020s or will the
2020 see the continued erosion of those
values in which we turn our major
communications platforms into public
utilities heavily controlled by the
state if we begin to treat media
consumption as a personal responsibility
with awareness of how electric media
predisposes us to tribalism and opens
new pathways of manipulation we can
better opt-out resist and persuade
others to do the same if things go well
the next decade could present new
opportunities to spread ideas free of
needless gatekeeping and to carve out
more robust spaces physical and virtual
away from prying eyes and heavy hands
spaces where individualism free thought
and experimentation can flourish if not
society could be destabilized in 2020s
or perhaps we'll see a new more
pernicious form of gatekeeping like the
techno authoritarian control mechanisms
being developed in China in that
scenario the only recourse will be to
turn more urgently to state resistant
encryption tools and decentralized
internet platforms a decentralized
framework where there isn't that
middleman that can be manipulated or
coerced or regulated into exposing your
data that's a better safer more
resilient world which doesn't end up in
this case where it's susceptible to
authoritarian
the future demands a greater commitment
to liberal tolerance of difference and
the fair and free exchange of ideas at
the coming decade with its opportunities
to leverage the tools that for so long
were out of reach for so many could and
should be a time of liberation choice
and prosperity rather than one of
collectivism control and misery
[Music]